en medio de escombros y del lodo así
quedaron los refugios de los rohingyas
en uno de los acampamentos más grandes
en cox's bazar debido a las lluvias que
han afectado el sureste de bangladesh
las lluvias monzónicas han provocado
deslizamientos de tierra e inundaciones
que ha dejado víctimas fatales y ha
llevado a miles de refugiados a verse
obligados a evacuar y mi hermana fue al
baño y después de que ella regresó la
ladera del cerro se vino abajo tengo una
sobrina y dos sobrinos y mi hermana mi
cuñado junto con otros miembros de la
familia lograron salir del albergue pero
el acantilado cayó sobre los cuatro y
todo el refugio resultó dañado dos de
ellos murieron y otros dos resultaron
heridos y es que las precarias
condiciones de las infraestructuras en
bambú y plástico facilitaron los
derrumbes en una región ya vulnerable a
los incendios e inundaciones según las
organizaciones humanitarias dejando aún
más complicada la situación de los
rohingyas que ya vivían en condiciones
de hacinamiento
estamos brindando alimentos y otras
asistencias a las familias afectadas y
estamos tratando de reubicar a otras
personas que están en riesgo
monitorearemos y situación más de medio
millón de rock and jazz que viven en los
acampamentos en cox's bazar han unido
desde 2017 de la violencia y la
persecución anti musulmana por parte del
ejército de mi llamar de mayoría budista
los asesinatos y las violaciones
ejercidas han sido calificadas por la
onu como limpieza étnica y hasta posible
genocidio